good morning millennials
welcome back
to the morning toast happy tuesday hope
everyone had a great long weekend well
your weekend wasn't long but ours was i
am joined in studio for the first
episode of the week with a replacement
co-host because jackie is still in
dallas and it is none other than the one
the only my husband
my rose is my husband ben sofer hey ben
a replacement co-host what else would it
be i don't know just like such a
horrific intro okay i'm joined by
a replacement co-host yeah that actually
you're right it was kind of like it's
like why am i even here i'm out because
you're replacing the co-host it's true
thank you for being here i know
i know you're beat up from a long
weekend celebrating good i'm good we are
dead yes we are dead human beings my
voice sounds a little weird but i feel
fine well i don't feel fine but i'm not
like sick
um
ben and i were journeying through all of
canada this past weekend i was in
toronto and then we were in montreal for
a wedding and and now um
like i will never be the same the way
that i talk like i've started to talk
differently because i've been in canada
for so long montrell you did what did
you say yesterday that i stopped you i'm
like
this is the word
you didn't stop me but i also noticed
that so
we happened to be in montreal for the um
for a wedding but it was also the big f1
race
which is called
g-r-a-n-p-r-i-x right grand prix um i've
been calling it because everyone i'm on
trails like grand prix
um so i was like grand prix grand prix
and i'm surprised you didn't make fun of
me for it it's grand prix it's grand
prix
but everyone in montreal was saying
grand prix got it grand prix grand prix
it's similar i think you're gonna say
that people here say it's pricks no no
no no what that's funny though um no so
i've just been like talking so
differently i feel like yeah grand prix
yeah we didn't go to grand prix though
by the way no we just happened to have a
wedding in montreal the same exact
weekend it was really fun i'm dead yeah
we only benefited from uh the three
times
flight prices so expensive canceled
airplanes oh my god i can't
i went to toronto on thursday and i
happened to be flying out to toronto the
same day that olivia was separately
flying from florida to new york jackie
was flying from new york to dallas and
every single one of our flights was
canceled it was a crazy weekend if you
travel this weekend like i feel for you
i don't know what's going on people are
not okay i think there's like labor
shortages it's just atrocious i had two
flights cancel on me in one day i can't
even get into it because i have so much
trauma but all i want to say is that i
um will never leave my home again
the wedding though was gorgeous yeah i
just want to say oh yeah i'm not i'm not
clowning on the wall before we [ __ ] all
over
montreal nobody but excuse me uh don't
speak for me i'm not planning on
cheating on montreal i have to talk
about their bagels yes you do but i just
wanted but i just want to say gorgeous
town gorgeous is amazing very clean
gorgeous was amazing is what i just said
wedding was amazing everything was
gorgeous town was gorgeous the trains so
clean i didn't take them so clean but
very nice town i agree like really clean
a little a little too many stop lights i
felt like to go five blocks it's a 30
minute journey because the lights like
there's so many and they don't go in
sync with each other they got to get
them in sync it was annoying but um
please go on your bagel uh tirade while
i have i just got so many dms asking me
what's better a montreal bagel or a new
york bagel as if it's a so i thought
wow i'm in for a treat these montreal
bagels must be amazing and i'm here to
tell you that they're dog [ __ ]
they're so thin
they're not good they taste like
gluten-free bagels really they're
terrible did you accidentally order
gluten-free bagels no uh
cream cheese tastes a little bit
different i don't know if it's the same
i don't know if the cows here are the
same as the cows there it's like
something about it it wasn't salty it
was very plain it tasted more pasty
so none of the locks that i had was good
out of ten what are you giving montreal
bagels a three the bagels i had were
were like significantly worse than an
l.a bagel a chicago bagel i've had
a thousand bagels outside of new york
within the united states that were
better than the montreal bagels that i
had it's a hot take
i don't think it is i think that the
people who ask montreal or new york was
that a good accent no
i don't know what that was montreal or
new york just have never been to new
york and never had a new york bagel they
just like what do you think about that
chain of bagel restaurant bagel like
shops that i think is called brooklyn
bagel that ship new york water to like
la and florida to make
bagels in florida with new york water
because if you don't know the reason why
new york bagels are the best is because
the new york water is different
and that's what goes into the dough so
there's a company that literally ships
barrels of new york water
all over the country to their own bagel
shops to make what they think are new
york bagels but like in san francisco
sounds like a ponzi scheme yeah
you don't believe it they're definitely
not shipping new york water nothing yeah
they're lying they're saying this is
made with new york water because
nobody's ever gonna [ __ ] taste the
difference because they live in los
angeles
they're shipping water that's such a
good call there's water there
they're not shipping water such a good
call they're lying wow they're lying
well we don't know for a fact you know
we don't want to get sued but who's what
company is it it's called brooklyn bagel
you've never seen like the i probably
have but i don't think you even think
it's you it's probably not good i've
never had it i thought it was i always
thought it was like an interesting
concept you know it's really not good
have you ever had einstein
never in my life that place einstein
bagel pops up everywhere there's an
einstein everywhere it's true and you
know speaking of bagels that reminds me
um i needed to talk about the new
laguardia airport
no
for those who don't know laguardia
airport has always been like an actual
crackdown like
it's literally always been tiny really
close to manhattan not a ton of flights
and not like it's not a premium
experience there's not like lounges and
restaurants and bars it's like you go
there you get in you get out it's quick
super close to the city you're not
spending hours there on a layover like
you're just going it's convenient it's
not glamorous and literally since i was
born they have been new laguardia like
redoing i literally have vivid memories
of being a six-year-old like going on
family vacation to florida pulling up
and it's like it's been a disaster
construction zone for years i think it's
totaling around five billion dollars is
what they've spent and recently like
they've started to open up these
terminals that they've been working on
for actually 50 years and i have to say
people are like i was talking about it
with a lot of people at the wedding they
were like oh my god it's amazing there's
an h bagels it's so clean and big like
people are so [ __ ] dumb it blows my
mind what they did to laguardia is a
disgrace it is a disgrace to humanity i
don't need an h h bagels i don't need a
fancy bookstore like literally i want to
walk one foot from my uber to the gate
that's what it used to be you could get
from your uber to the gate in literally
100 steps
now we got off the plane we were
wandering around this forlorn terminal
for 45 minutes a tunnel a terminal a
tunnel to another terminal oh no you
want to go to baggage club sorry 45
minute walk this way i was ready to
literally kill someone at the end of it
it was horrible so do i care that it's
like fancy there's an h bagels uh i
never go to h bagels in the city why the
[ __ ] would i go in the airport who cares
airports are not meant for lounging so
everyone who's like oh my god it's
amazing all these restaurants shut up
like you're dumb like you're literally
so dumb and stupid i hate the new
laguardia literally every person
who contributed to making it the
concrete [ __ ] that it is like
deserves jail for life and i will never
after what i experienced yesterday i
will never literally you will never
catch me my big fat ass in laguardia
airport ever [ __ ] again [ __ ] you do
airports get paid for by taxpayer
dollars probably people's products
that's upsetting people's priorities
though are really out of whack it's very
bizarre no okay ready you don't need
restaurants because the idea is that
you're not supposed to spend a lot of
time there or money yeah well whatever
okay here i have a perfect example i've
been on tour for a while i've been to
literally every airport
and i would say the best airport in the
entire world
is it kansas city it's kansas city
missouri
now i'll have you know the first time i
went to kansas city missouri i was
posting on instagram like so excited to
be doing a show in kansas city people
were sending me messages like we're so
sorry about the airport like don't let
it be a reflection of how you feel about
st
kansas city do not like let it don't
don't hate us because of the airport so
i'm like what am i walking into
because to me the definition of a
terrible airport is something huge with
walks to your gate that take 45 minutes
walks to the ground transportation that
take an hour
so my imagine my surprise i land
at kansas city
and i get into a taxi
i swear to god
45 seconds after stepping off the plane
it's literally the airport can't be more
than a thousand square feet is the
craziest thing there's not a starbucks
there's literally one little man selling
muffins it's
literally like the most low budget thing
and it is the best airport i've ever
seen like normalized not liking airports
that are fancy it's a scam and people
are so dumb for believing it it's
bothering the [ __ ] out of me like we had
one nice thing we had laguardia it was
small it wasn't fancy it was tiny and it
was convenient and now it's ruined just
like everything else this is why we can
have
nice things
what do you think is actually the best
because look
that airport
sounds nice it's incredible particular
situation that you have you can get to
your flight 20 minutes before it's
incredible if you can get to your vlog
20 minutes before then it's a great
airport but i was going to say i think
the best airport in the country let's
say i know you're going to say okay
let's get on the counter
no one wait are we saying the name or
the acronym
the name i don't know the acronym i only
know the acronym other than we're saying
different ones okay i'm not saying new
work or you no terrible it's pvi oh pbi
is really good nantucket is also good no
pbi the palm beach airport is the
perfect blend of we have some food like
a little pizzeria so you can get a nice
snack
but it's small but we're not overdoing
it we're not overdoing it you're not
gonna have to walk more than 10 minutes
to find your gate yeah i agree that's
it's a great airport gorgeous and i'm
trying to think where i went recently
that was like the worst it was somewhere
in texas huge like trams i hate i hate a
train okay but you know what i don't
hate a tram because if my alternative is
walking to my gate i'm taking that
[ __ ] tram no tram is better for sure
i like a tram so i'm just like bent out
of shape and i don't think i'll ever be
traveling ever again like i think
traveling is
it's not for me it's not for me you
don't want to go to florida
i know it's not for me
like i can't imagine getting back on a
plane after what i've been through
florida now before we dive in i had a
few more things i wanted to talk about
okay um
the first is literally what i woke up
for today like the reason for the season
the reason why i'm here today is to talk
about the summer i turned pretty which
is the new show on amazon based off of
the three books the trilogy by jenny han
um which i read last summer and
loved so much and i've been waiting for
this tv show to come out it's on amazon
prime if you haven't watched it
go watch it it's so good if you're
thinking about reading the books before
i highly recommend the first season of
this show only covers the first book so
you only have to read the first one um
you watched a couple episodes with me
but like when i tell you i've never
not never but i can't remember like a
time in recent history where i've been
so obsessed with the tv show
one because i read the book so i'm like
super invested in it two i love the
concept you know it's like that preteen
coming of age story you know you're
start like it was just it was too much
and the soundtrack so
i can't also remember a time in recent
memory where i was so impacted by the
soundtrack of a tv show it was
incredible i couldn't have chose the
songs better myself we had olivia
rodrigo we had so much taylor swift we
had billy eilish we had bleachers we had
phoebe bridgers i've been listening to
the soundtrack playlist on spotify it's
so good i just like i spent every free
moment i had this weekend thank god
shout out to the w in montreal for
having amazon prime because i don't know
what i would have done they had it on
the tv it was so premium i [ __ ] loved
it now i have a few things like
obviously i wasn't obsessed with that
i'll get into in one second but before i
say the negative i just want to say i
loved everything about it they had a few
changes you know if you read the book
a lot of people were like all bent out
of shape like they changed so much i
actually didn't think that they changed
that much and when you do adapt a book
like you have to change some things so
here's what they changed one
jeremiah is bisexual which i don't
believe he was in the book but doesn't
really change anything so who cares
um the other thing that they changed was
a lot of the show was centered around
around the debutante ball which is like
not a thing in the book but it also
didn't bother me because i thought they
the way they did it was really visually
stunning and like that scene you guys
know where i don't want to spoil it i
won't spoil it but like when that's the
way i loved you came on like
dead like it was it was so good i know
you watched a couple episodes with me um
but like who cares because i'm talking
i'm just gonna say
you can stop saying that i realized that
like i haven't let you talked in a while
but like i just need to get this on my
chest the one thing i did not like about
the show the one thing that i did not
like
was this
oh also another thing that was not in
the book was cleveland castillo but i
kind of liked that little um edition so
i didn't mind
the one thing i didn't like was and the
person who i thought was miss cast which
upsets me deeply because i actually
really like this character um with
susanna i thought the actress who played
susanna was like giving community
theater it was giving like
bad acting and i was just like kind of
cringing in a lot of her scenes which is
sad because she's an important character
and she's from seventh heaven and the
clueless tv show like she's an iconic tv
actress did you remember that i do now
did you watch seventh grade of course so
good they know there's no better
and then love of family
seventh heaven it's weird how much like
christian family vibes got into my
incredibly jewish home so true it's an
amazing point same with us yeah just
like what no but seven seven
i mean amazing show yeah but didn't
something terrible happen with them the
the dad i think he's like in jail he's
like he turned out to be like literally
like an enormous predator that's what it
was yeah like i think his name is steven
something he's like disgusting um but
still seven heaven slaps so watch it
like i can i loved it so much i've been
in like a tv hangover ever since i don't
think i'll ever be that happy again my
life was so good when i had episodes in
front of me the fact that they made it
seven episodes 45 minutes like it's not
long enough i loved every minute of it
it was so beautifully done i don't know
where they shot it but it was just
gorgeous i loved it it was so good and
that's what i wanted to say
here on the toast today and now i'm
ready to move on anything else you want
to talk about before we dive into the
past five stories oh
i do i basically i'm doing a podcast a
long time
sorry it's just we haven't been on since
thursday so there's like a lot of
catching up to do um breaking bread for
those who missed the live show last week
it's up on spotify you can listen to it
on demand we are like um i don't know
the most popular [ __ ] on spotify
we're number two like literally under
joe rogan number two not even in comedy
like overall isn't that crazy crazy i
saw that when i woke up yesterday the
day before and i was shooketh so new
episode is going to be live tomorrow so
if you want to watch live of course
spotify live the app you can watch it
live there you can also watch it live on
spotify but if you miss it they're
always on demand um starting on fridays
so
yeah
um okay now i'm ready i'm sorry i had
like five things i needed to like get
off my chest don't be sorry
you're carrying the show but now i'm
ready to do an amazing show with my
replacement co-host oh sorry i just need
to crack my neck you think they can hear
the crack in the microphone um probably
not cool pen loves to crack his neck i
really do wish i could sometimes i'm
like oh if only i could just crack my
neck yeah but the problem is once you
crack it then you need to crack it and
crack it and crack it and crack it how
many times i'm a slave to the crack how
many times a day you crack your neck i
don't even know at this point all the
time and all of a sudden like five years
i'm gonna wake up unbelievably arthritic
yeah not being able to move my neck 100
because of these like little cracks that
i do meanwhile you long term your neck
is going to be perfect you should work
on stopping that then no it's done it's
like smoking cigarettes totally that's
it i'm addicted to the crack okay well i
feel like without further a do
where are you um it's time for the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toes
oh [ __ ] i forgot that you do that you
work annoying
congratulations you beat the cringe um
congratulations beat it ben you played
yourself
um also for those wondering jackie is
back in studio tomorrow she is traveling
back from dallas today and she did a
meet and greet at specs um for spritz
and i heard it went amazing i did too i
heard it was just sold out affair the
girlies came
in excess
it looked it looked unbelievable yeah me
by the way i just said meanwhile
if you'd like a code have you tried
peach i don't know if you've tried peach
but you should try peach
code life's a peach
l-i-f-e-s-a-p-e-a-c-h
at spurtsociety.com great code great
product enjoy it
enjoy it you're going to like the way
you look i guarantee it by the way men's
warehouse i know what you're going to
say unbelievable do you never really
shop there no one does
it's unbelievably sad but no you have to
you have to be down on your luck
walk in there and then you're met with
this amazing surprise that there is some
stuff in there that isn't [ __ ] right
because we had so many wedding events a
lot of them were themed like one of the
nights was a white party i wasn't going
to buy a white linen suit for two
thousand dollars that was gonna get like
two thousand immediately dirty yeah
that's what regular suits are like uh
between a thousand and two thousand
dollars that's murano it could be even
more that's literally the dumbest thing
shoots are very expensive so you went to
men's warehouse and you found love in a
hopeless place unbelievable white linen
suit i'm sorry 400 bucks was it linen
yes you looked great i know can you move
your mic a little closer we're recording
a podcast you couldn't hear me no i
can't hear you yeah
can't he tell us if he can't hear me no
but see we have to be like the same
distance away from the microphone you
know mm-hmm
don't worry you'll get it you'll get it
um okay let's dive in today's story is
brought to you by the starbucks bia
energy drink with caffeine naturally
found in coffee fruit it's energy that's
good it's a beverage that's crafted from
the caffeine naturally found in coffee
fruit as well as antioxidant vitamin c
comes in three delicious fruity flavors
mango guava raspberry lime and pineapple
passion fruit it is a refreshing flu
flavored boost of feel-good energy in a
way that only starbucks can deliver each
12-ounce 90-calorie can contains 160
milligrams of caffeine we have them here
in the studio you guys know i don't
really love coffee but sometimes when
you're looking for like an energy boost
and i'm not gonna like drink cold brew i
just don't like it um i find it really
delicious mango guava is fire and you
can find them pretty much everywhere so
the energy drink is available online
it's at grocery stores convenience
stores and uh gas stations nationwide so
check it out if you're looking for a
caffeine alternative they're incredibly
delicious and i highly recommend them
today's episode is also brought to you
by manscaped summer is here the sun is
shining and your man's balls are
smoother than timothy chalamet's chest
picture yourself all cheeked up on the
beach this summer with not a hair in
sight peeking from your bikini line and
his trunks you can skip the brazilian
this summer and use manscaped for smooth
tools that you trust for your man and
for yourself
their performance package 4.0 features
the trimmer that everyone loves that's
what you have been they have the
lawnmower 4.0 that's what it's called
and you can dive first into summer by
joining the four million people
worldwide who trust manscaped and get
ready for hot girl summer by going to
manscape.com for 20 off and free
shipping when you use the code toast so
the performance package 4.0 which is
exactly what you have that you take with
you everywhere um it has everything you
need for the perfect summer bod inside
it you'll find the lawn mower 4.0
trimmer the weed whacker nose and hair
ear nose and hair trimmer on the crop
preserver ball deodorant crop reviver
toner performance boxer briefs and the
travel bag which we literally just
unpacked today
um
for anywhere you're going this summer
the lawnmower 4.0 features a cutting
edge ceramic blade to reduce grooming
accidents thanks to their advanced skin
safe technology also that it has a 4000k
led spotlight that you can turn on and
off for a precise shave every time get
20 off and free shipping with code toast
at manscaped that's 20 off plus free
shipping with the code toast at
manscaped.com
buns out sun's out this summer with
manscaped ladies
are you ready it is a great razor i know
you love it
we're getting starbucks ads yeah that's
incredibly cool good for you um okay
so first story is some broadway news and
normally i don't care about broadway
news but this is like
you know how much this means to me once
i tell you the headline ready leah
michelle
might finally be funny girl on broadway
after beanie feldstein is bailing wow so
the rumor is no laughing matter for leah
michelle fans the 35 year old was
reportedly the producer's pick to pick
play fanny bryce and funny girl once
beenie feldstein leads the role in
september according to showbiz 4-1-1 a
representative for lee michelle declined
to comment when she was contacted by new
york post um
but michelle has publicly manifested her
desire to play the barbra streisand
original character for years she got a
taste on the first season of glee when
she's saying don't rain on my parade she
also performed the show tune at the 2010
tony awards so let's unpack this
let me give you like the debrief so you
know i know everything but do you know
that like
i don't know why beanie feldstein's
stepping back besides the fact that
people
said it's not good so beanie feldstein
was playing this role for six months
which for like a a major a-lister lead
role this is what people like on tick
tock who are broadway experts are saying
like it's very uncommon like she should
be staying longer jane lynch is also
leaving who plays beanie feldstein's mom
fanny brice's mom in the play but for
like for not a main character that's
common after six months but like for a
headliner what people are saying it's
it's kind of weird but there's been a
lot of weirdness so when they announced
that funny girl was becoming a broadway
show of course everyone was like lea
michelle not only because she looks so
much like a young barbra streisand she's
been like a barbra streisand uh
advocate like her whole life she's
obsessed with barbra streisand then her
character in glee was obsessed with
playing funny girl angley she did in the
sixth season eventually get to like
become the role of fanny bryce whatever
and anytime they've ever been asked
about a funny girl broadway revival it's
always been lea michelle but then lea
michelle had some like bad press
um like a little over a year ago and
then they announced that the show was
coming and i think that like the
producers either didn't want to work
with her because of her bad press or for
whatever reason and they went with
beanie feldstein which i thought was
such a bizarre choice i didn't even know
that she sang
um and i have seen a couple clips on
tick tock of her performance and i have
to say it is underwhelming to say the
least like
the song specifically don't rain on my
parade is such a big song you need like
someone with a huge voice who can belt
and i was when i saw a clip of her scene
like the the climax of that song i was
i was shook i was like this is
terrible
um and so the fact that she's leaving is
crazy because it's been such a short
amount of time and if lea michelle does
get it like i do think it will be
so much better than than beanie
feldstein
yeah i mean her voice is amazing her
voice is amazing she is the character
wasn't her bad press that she's like
mean
yeah that like because maybe it's not
the bad press maybe they didn't want to
work with somebody that's mean
well like i assume that she's an
absolute nightmare to work with well the
thing is is like well yes
i think maybe they they didn't choose
her i think they didn't choose her
because of the bad press because
everyone in hollywood is difficult to
work with and i don't think liam
michelle is exceptionally different than
anyone else i just think she got called
out
publicly interesting so and like brands
were dropping her it was like her little
cancellation got it but i do think if
she does get this role like that will
officially be behind her like that whole
but it has really affected her for a
long time yeah she's been like very
quiet she had a baby like she hasn't
really worked a ton but now she's doing
this spring awakening thing on hbo max
she's like getting more involved back
especially with broadway so i do think
that like
her time has come i'm sure she's like
swallowing like a you know a lot of her
pride and eating humble pie the fact
that like she's having to take the role
from beanie feldstein and she wasn't
like the
first choice for everyone she could
think about it like that but if she came
and did it it would be significantly
better and you know how much i hate
broadway shows yeah but i would see this
in a second like i would go to opening
night i would do everything i can to get
tickets for sure it's
it's literally like
it's me playing tracy turnblad like
things just make sense you know
it's you know
it's kismet you know and as much as you
might not likely michelle you have to
admit like no one could play this role
on the planet better than her
and i hope that this is true and i guess
we'll find out agreed justice for lea
michelle might be
might be coming around might get served
um and we're happy for her so um i
actually know a lot of people that went
to see funny girl really
and or by a lot of people i mean two
different sets of people okay and both
times beanie feldstein was out yeah
yeah she seems to have been out a lot
it's just been like a really weird thing
that she did because i don't really
think that people were expecting it to
be her
i do love that she's a jewish queen
because like it's such a jewish role
um
and lee michelle i believe is half
jewish um so it's like it's authentic
but i don't think it was the right thing
for her i think it made her like look
bad i think a lot of people you're right
saw her understudy do it who i heard was
great
they've just been like whispers that
she's not been like pleasant like
i don't think it was the right move for
beanie especially coming off of the uh
tv show what which what was it called
that we watch about um monica lewinsky
where she was impeachment incredible
impeachment she was amazing amazing she
was amazing in it but maybe what you're
saying is why she's been out maybe the
song is just a little bit too big yeah i
think the role is too big for her maybe
it's just bad casting i think it was
poor casting and i think like the way
they went out of their way to not give
it to liam michelle um because of her
bad press
was silly because now i think they're
going to go with her anyway
later i do think it should have been her
to start
um all right well that's your little
broadway news that we don't really talk
about but um we'll keep you updated on
whether or not that's actually true we
could have just liked on a 20-minute
conversation about something that's not
even true because it's uh just a rumor
but speaking of rumors khloe kardashian
might have a new man she's dating a
private equity investor that she met
through kim
so khloe kardashian has a new man in her
life page six can confirm a source tells
us that the kardashian star is currently
dating a private equity investor she met
through her older sister kim kardashian
the insider says that chloe and her
mystery man were introduced at a dinner
party a few weeks ago and that the two
hit it off the relationship it is in its
early stages and chloe's feeling really
good according to people who broke the
news on monday additionally we're told
that chloe and her ex-boyfriend tristan
thompson do not talk unless it's about
their daughter the four-year-old true
thompson over the weekend the good
american founder shut down rumors that
she was seeing another nba player people
were like starting rumors that chloe was
seeing some guy she shut it down on
instagram she said it's definitely not
true
um after they thought she was dating the
chicago bulls center forward it was on
dumoin um who's the center forward of
the chicago bulls
oh no no sorry
they heard she was dating another
basketball player after she split from
the chicago bulls center forward is that
tristan
like
he's the backup
also who says center forward no it's one
position this is the center why didn't
they just say he's the backup center why
didn't they just say after they should
say chicago bulls loser no they should
say chica
after her certainly not the chicago
bulls center forward no one if you say
chicago bulls center forward no one will
ever say tristan thompson okay what we
were saying is like she also this
article could have just said after her
split from tristan thompson or it could
say
like if they want to talk about him as
it relates to the league
former like cleveland cavaliers champion
kristen thompson kristen what did i say
kristen
tristan thompson
center forward bulls
yeah i don't even know if he's the
backup he might be the backups backup
yeah no he's definitely not good anymore
um it's not that he's not good he's just
not in their rotation but this is not
the part of the story that i care about
the part of the story this is part of
the story that i care about i know but
the part of the story that's like so
important is that khloe kardashian has a
businessman beau which we have been
saying on this show for years is exactly
what you need you know she's been dating
athletes and fellow celebrities who
don't treat her with the respect that
she deserves she's been cheating on
cheated on and treated poorly by so many
men i'm sure um i'm sure she'll get
she'll be treated really well by a
private equity man are you being
sarcastic they tend to have like
great morals yeah what do you mean you
want a great man go find a farmer
private equity it doesn't even mean
anything no it's dc
but can i say i'm so glad she's going in
a different direction
this is totally different than what
she's done before which is like really
athlete after athlete so at least she's
changing you know a little bit maybe
this isn't going to be the thing you
know that relationship to end all
relationships but at least she's looking
for love in different places because it
hasn't really worked out for her in the
past and me and jackie have always said
she needs a businessman bo someone who's
focused on like running a business not
being a celebrity just being you know
wealthy on her level can take her places
but isn't like thirsting out trying to
get you know
ride her coattails
she needs a pete davidson
like yes but i think that this is way
closer to her pete davidson than
anything she's ever had no she needs a
fun
go with the flow
not trying to be on her level this guy
is going to try to be on her level like
flashing all this cash she doesn't need
any cash no but that's a nice guy no
that's the thing with like rich
businessmen is that they have money they
don't need fame most people if you have
money what's that what's that phrase
hold on no before you interrupt me
what's that phrase it's like
you know what let me not botch you if
you don't need fame you're not dating
khloe kardashian
i'm sorry if you have
if you're an unbelievably successful
private equity man
you're not dating chloe unless you're
looking for fame
okay that was a great call to not even
it's bill murray well i didn't realize
it was bill murray i always like to say
people who want to be rich and famous
try being rich first and see if that
doesn't cover most of it so it's like
rich people don't need to be famous but
famous people like do need to be rich so
a famous older you know businessman is
going to be secure he's not he doesn't
need to be famous he's rich if he
doesn't need to be famous then why is he
seeking khloe kardashian because he
probably runs in like elite circles and
he look how could you not meet chloe and
be taken by her she's an incredibly
special soul if you've been watching
this most recent season of kardashians
you know she's a really special type of
person perhaps you know he found love in
an unexpected place she seems
incredible fantastic
not saying anything bad about her i am
saying that if he was looking if he's
like so financially secure set great
looking to settle down wants no fame
he's probably not seeking her out i just
don't choose to believe you because i
see the business men bow in a different
light than you do um and you are being
negative so um okay
that's on you cool
yeah i don't like this i love it like
i'm so pleased for chloe especially
after watching this most recent season
and you see how like she shows up for
every single person in her family like
100 supportive does everything to lift
them up lift them up meanwhile her
personal life is going down the drain
it's like every morning she's getting a
call tristan had a baby with someone
else like it's
someone like that deserves unconditional
love i'm not saying that this is gonna
be it but i'm glad that she's getting
back out there and that she's changing
the type of guy she's going after that's
all i'll say how about that that's fun
okay fair
great i'm glad we agree cool we have
some tragic music news coming up that's
brought to you by bowling branch
bowling branch sheets aren't just
buttery breathable and impossibly
comfortable they get softer with every
wash forget the thread count bowlin
branch is giving you thread quality
because it doesn't matter how many
threads you your sheets have if they
aren't the best threads possible so we
are bowling branch girlies i don't know
if you even know that our entire bedding
is from bowling branch
we have the signature hemmed collection
sheets from bowlin branch and it is
their best seller for a reason they use
the highest quality threads on earth
they have superior softness and a better
night's sleep their sheets are are made
with threads that are so luxurious that
they've been beloved by three u.s
presidents did you know you're sleeping
in a bed that's good enough for three
u.s presidents which
doesn't say i don't think they want to
get political they feel buttery to the
touch they are super breathable and
they're perfect for every season as
someone who gets extremely warm in her
sleep it was really important to me to
find sheets that were breathable that
didn't suffocate me and that's why i
love bowling branch most importantly
because i don't wake up in a pool of my
own sweat
they have over 10 000 stellar reviews
and you can get 15 off your first set of
sheets when you use the promo code toast
at
bowlingbranch.com that's bowlin branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d branch dot com promo code
toast great cheats
great sheets um are you ready for our
tragic music news yes
marcus
sorry no that's not what it says
mumford and sons if you have to cough
just like do it out like having terrible
just allergies take my zyrtec my eyes
are itchy
i need like a zyzol or uh
jumping i actually hate i hate zaizal i
love their mascot don't be wise all
that owl amazing it's cute but who takes
zeisel
um actually a lot of people no i mean
it's claritin or zyrtec 100 size might
as well be like dwayne reed so you're
saying you're not getting wise all and
you're not taking zaizal i want to meet
the owl i don't want their product 100
um okay bumford and son's lead singer
marcus mumford is going solo really yeah
so um mumford and i'm saying do they
sing
uh
they sing so many who are you
i think our voices are good for this now
they're so good i've been like in
college i was like a big mumford and
sons girlies mostly because i thought
like it would make boys like me but i
actually ended up really liking their
music
um and mumford and sons might just be
bumford soon
so sources tell us is his name mr
mumford marcus mumford yeah and i don't
think the other band members are his
sons but ooh
well that would be a much sadder split
yeah of course daddy's leaving disowns
his sons to go solo so sources inside
spotify soiree
sources inside spotify soiree at a
french villa on monday tell page six
exclusively that the music's group
leader marcus mumford announced that he
will be focusing on his solo career he's
married to actress carrie mulligan whom
he shares two children with he made the
stunning announcement while performing
for an intimate group in the hills of
the french riviera he also said he was
performing new music for the first time
and that it would be available on
spotify as it was a sponsor spotify
sponsored event anyways he just said
today is day one for his next thing the
party attendee told page six and the rep
for mumford 35 and spotify did not
immediately return page six's request
for comment
um and so like while this is tragic
because i do feel like um
mumford and sons has been like
they're like a coldplay like they're
like iconic it's a bad call really no
well first of all they're not a cold
play oh that's about what's a bad call
well there are a lot of bad calls here
okay the first bad call is by you
comparing mumford and sons to coldplay i
think that they're like
a more niche alternative like but i
think they're
just as popular as like they do crazy
concerts they're not even close to as
popular it's coldplay i think you're
right that's one i'm not saying they're
not as popular as coldplay but i think
that like they could be in like in 10
years a coldplay
i'll tell you why they're not coldplay
because if chris martin said i'm going
on my own
it would be like when i totally just i
think it's so in the needs is banned i
disagree okay
because
i know what you're saying like if what's
mr mumford's first name marcus did you
know that yes you knew his name was
married to carrie mulligan from great
gatsby i don't even know who karen
mulligan is only mulligan i know is in
golf people don't know karen mulligan
they don't know mrs mulligan
they don't miss they don't know mr
mumford i'm telling you you don't but
people do marcus mumford is like is
famous in his own right and while i
don't think it would be like the same
level of chris martin leaving coldplay i
do think it would be similar if adam
levine left maroon 5. like he's the only
person whose name in marcus in mumford
and sons i literally even know i know
but people know adam levine because of
oh sorry people know adam levine because
of is it american idol or the voice or
he's on tv people know his name mr
mumford i don't nobody knows who mr
mumford is because mr mumford isn't in
an indie band so like they're not being
thirsty going on the voice exactly why
he can't have a solo career i think
you're wrong
we'll see i think it'll like i think if
i if if what i assume is correct in that
like he writes a lot of the songs um i
think it they will remain totally
uneffective and just i think because
you're clouding like your familiarity
with mumford and sons and marcus mumford
with like the general perception i think
you're wrong i think that
my general perception
i i know the things that i know because
people are of a certain level of fame
for me to know about them
do you understand what i'm saying yeah
he's not in like in the pr world he
doesn't have that q score he's not there
no i'm i hear what you're saying he's
not getting these gillette commercials
adam levine he's an indie artist i don't
do that adam levine has cali rosa he was
able to launch his own tequila mister
is a [ __ ] first monster who will
literally go to the opening of an
envelope to get paid and that's exactly
why he could go solo marcus mumford is
one of these like indie artists who like
has integrity and like won't do my new
voice i sound like jeff garland we're
not okay no i literally do you hear the
way that i said i also want to say why
this is not surprising and i remember
this from like a year ago one of the
other band members left because like he
wanted to be able to post freely he was
like getting political or something and
like his band mates like weren't into it
so he just decided like i'm out i want
to be able to like post what i want
about politics or whatever and it was
like kind of a big deal that he left so
mumford and sons like hasn't been okay
for a while that's why i would say i'm
not that surprised you should give my
final analogy oh here wait sorry while
you're wrong here's marcus mumford at
the met gala okay i've never seen that
man in my life you're so wrong i've
never seen him in my life and also
marcus mumford's hot i just want to put
it out there nobody knows who mr mumford
is and what i will say is
this analogy is do you remember when
shaquille o'neal
left the lakers no he went to the
cavaliers and then he went to the
celtics and then he went to the suns and
he just wouldn't let his career die oh
i didn't know that but that's about it
mr mumford's going solo to a painful
death
okay you're either mumford and sons or
your mumford and nuns okay you know what
i think another good comparison is and
like even though we keep going back and
forth over comparisons it would be like
if zach brown left zach brownband it's
literally the band named after him but
totally people literally only know zac
zack brown and zack brown is so
successful he could go out on his own
and do his own thing and i think marcus
mumford is the same but you know what
we'll have to watch this episode in a
year and see what happens
so i will say though i will say
your credit
mumford and sons peak was definitely
like when i was in college like a couple
years ago um
so i don't know if he's gonna be huge
but i think he has a chance that's what
i'll say i think he has no chance i
think zach brown of zack brownband
also would have a difficult time without
his band being just a solo performer
because when you build a band around
your name
it's you in the band right no that's the
opposite when you build a band around
just your name nobody knows anyone else
except the guy whose name is in the
title of the band yeah but it's also
camaraderie it's the bus it's them
having good laughs yeah the bus it's all
the bus 100 but zach brown at least i
know zach brown's name
i know his first name zach because it's
zach brown bands i don't know mr mumford
okay we'll just have to say but let us
know in the comments marcus
it doesn't fit doesn't fit what he
should change his name and go solo 100
um all right a little bit more
kardashian news rob kardashian and blac
chyna have reached a settlement in their
revenge porn case so i don't know
revenge porn i don't know if you
remember the vagina case of like 2000 no
i want to say 15 or 16 they were like
going through this messy ass breakup and
he literally posted a picture of her
vagina on instagram at like nine in the
morning and it was incredibly shocking
and we were doing the morning breath at
the time so we were live
and literally our phones were blowing up
and we look up and we saw a vagina
before noon and it was shocking that's
not good so that's revenge porn it is
illegal and they've been in court for a
while now but rob kardashian and blac
chyna have reached a settlement ahead of
their jury selection in their revenge
porn case a clerk at the la county
superior court informed us on monday
morning that the exes had come to an
agreement though the terms remain
unclear potential jurors were already
lined up outside the courthouse who are
all these loose-lipped clerks
totally who is it that just like there's
just somebody that walks in and it's
like give me all of the private details
and there's this random clerk that just
pops out and spills it's not private
like court documents are public
information got it that's how tmz like
finds out all this stuff got it so
potential jurors were lining up outside
the courthouse like because they were
going to be selected for jury duty but
they were dismissed given the last
minute update that they reached a
settlement which is so nice for the
people who were selected for jury duty
that day they got to bounce i forgot to
tell you you know what i found in my bag
a summons for you
what yeah you must have put it in there
thinking it was for me you have jury
duty okay but why did you just say that
on the podcast because like now i have
to go yeah you have to i hate you we
need to cut this out because then i
could say because then i could say i
never got it you know yeah no it's in my
bag
i hate you sorry you're not an idiot
um
whatever they reached a settlement this
is finally over
i hate you more than life
[Music]
[Laughter]
i have to run a business i can't like
pick up for two days and go to jury duty
i
whatever
china and rob have reached the
settlement
um it doesn't say how much the amount is
but
blac chyna just had to pay the
kardashians like a ton of money because
she lost the lawsuit against them so i'm
glad she won this one because homegirl's
gonna need some money like she's been
paying legal bills she's been losing
left right and center she finally won
one i'm assuming rob had to pay her
because he literally posted a picture of
her vagina on the internet um so that's
good and i hope she got a nice amount
because i think she needs it
rob in china i could like literally
write a whole dissertation on how that
was the most psychotic time in pop
culture like
i can't even like think about it it's so
crazy
i never heard about vagina you didn't
no well
that's crazy how long was it up like a
decent amount of time
it was like it was so crazy i'll never
forget the image of her vagina
and it stayed up
as long as instagram would allow it
because it's like porn how long do you
think it stayed up i don't know
a decent amount of time enough for us to
do a podcast on it wow and you know once
something's up on the internet it lives
on twitter and read it forever so it
doesn't even matter if it got taken down
interesting that i never heard that
they're so good at burying press no
kardashians no or i just missed it first
of all it was
six years ago
i guess wow that's so crazy no not six
four
and it was huge but this was just like
one of a thousand things that happened
with rob in china in the course of like
those toxic few months and then she got
pregnant so this was just one of many
things but i think that maybe like you
just weren't paying attention because it
wasn't buried it was insane
it was like the biggest thing that
happened that year how stupid
so dumb like how could you be so dumb
but this is just a lesson to everyone
like don't post a picture of your ex's
genitals on social media you might get
sued because it is illegal it's called
revenge porn and it's
it's not okay no it's [ __ ] up um we
have one more fifth and final story it's
about salads which you know are my
favorite um it's brought to you by fly
by jing be honest you're bored of the
food you cook life gets in the way and
before you know it you're making the
same chicken and vegetables dish that
you've made every night this week and
it's time to spice it up
have you had fly by jinx sauces yet they
are elevating recipes and meals fly by
jing is the first modern chinese food
company in america and has put spicy
chili crisp on the map the versatile
delicious chinese hot sauce that's
taking the us by storm it is the
quickest and easiest way to bring
restaurant quality flavors to your home
and spice up whatever you're eating fly
by jing is on a mission to bring premium
chinese flavors to every table they make
the highest quality szechuan sauces and
pantry essentials that taste good on
everything all the ingredients are 100
vegan all natural and non-gmo
the triple threat is fly by jinx
best-selling trio of addictive szechuan
sauces it's the szechuan chili crisp the
zhong sauce and the mala spice mix
you'll find yourself putting them on
everything are you ready to step up your
game and elevate your favorite recipes
get 15 off your entire order at
flybyjing.com
toast or just use code toast at checkout
that's
dot flybyjing.com slash toast for 15 off
your first order you can also find fly
by jing in over 2 500 locations across
the country including costco whole foods
target and wegmans um all right fifth
and final story is some salad news like
i said because jennifer aniston is
responding to the claims that she ate
this viral tic tac salad every day on
the set of friends i saw this so this
recipe's been going viral on tick tock
and they were like i'm gonna make the
salad that jennifer aniston ate for 10
years for lunch every day while she was
on the set of friends and it's like
literally not a salad it's like a dip
it's like chickpeas i didn't think there
was any lettuce chickpeas
quinoa lentils it was like
a macaroni salad it was so weird um and
people have just been making it i don't
know where the rumors started that this
was the
salad she ate every day um but jennifer
aniston
has addressed the fact that it is not
the salad that she was eating so it's
made up of bulgur wheat or quinoa diced
cucumber red onion chickpeas pistachios
feta cheese mint and lemon juice it
started making the rounds on tik tok
earlier this year with recipe videos
racking up over 10 million views
but
um
who calls quinoa bulgur wheat no no it's
it's you can either have burger wheat or
quinoa i don't think they're saying
what's the same burger wheat you would
know more than me like i have no idea
never heard of that so the first salad
um it went viral back in 2010 when
courtney cox revealed that the pair had
eaten a cobb salad together every time
they were on set
um
but it wasn't a really cobb salad it was
a salad that jennifer doctored up with
turkey bacon garbanzo beans whatever
so now jennifer aniston is like doing
press
um and she said well that salad dare i
debunk that that's not the salad i had
every day on friends i feel terrible
because it's literally taken off like
crazy and it looks like a delicious
salad by the way but that's not the one
i had on friends i would never have that
much chickpea in a salad to be honest
not good for the digestive tract so for
all these people who spent hours making
chickpea salad on tick tock um i don't
know what you were doing with your life
but that's what you get for eating a
salad can you imagine being so skinny
that you'd say that chickpeas are not
good for your digestive tract no it
literally couldn't be me i've never had
a chickpea i'm sorry too much chickpeas
today i've never had a chickpea in my
life because these are great you've had
chickpeas
i don't really like hummus you do
sometimes
no a light shmear no like actually sorry
i've never had hummus you've had almost
no i haven't also hummus i know on the
podcast
on the podcast i'm not going to say
hummus but like when i'm with my jewish
friends i have to say hummus because
they're like hummus and then on the
podcast if i'm like homeless people are
like claudia hummus so podcast is com
podcast is hummus
friends
it's not hummus anywhere
it's hummus for literally all of america
that's who moose
no because like we are literally
authentic mediterranean jews
we say hummus at a minimum it's a humus
no it's hummus no
it's definitely not there's a ooh
moose
it's either a moose or a hummus it's
hummus it's not a hummus
what's hummus what do you say hummus
thank you the american eyes version is
hummus what's happening we're like so
like foreign and like international and
like cosmopolitan hummus
i love you more than life but like it's
hummus
it's not humus like it's never been
humus
it's not umu's definitely not umu's but
it's hummus yes to the point i made
earlier is i've never had hummus
you're missing out no i don't think that
i am no it's delicious you'd also love
it with schnitzel on a pita yeah cool me
um those are the first five stories you
definitely did not need to know them
except for like maybe the first two um
i'm excited about leah michelle on funny
girl that may or may not happen and if
you do want to talk into your microphone
um that would be awesome for people
listening
should i say it again yeah because you
were like literally yawning pulling
backwards i said it really loud okay
i think people heard me okay um well i
know how busy you are because you've
been you know traveling and you have
work to do so i just want to say i
really appreciate you being here thank
you darling the toasters love you um
always a good day when brunch is on the
toast so thank you for making the time
for us we really appreciate it you know
our little show
um
it means a lot it's a glorious show and
you've been a great replacement co-host
today yeah it's a terrible name
um so thank you for being here thank you
darling thank you to everyone who
you know listened i hope you enjoyed it
i hope that it brought you peace
and that's our show thank you so much
for listening thank you so much for
listening to the morning testimony
morning show where we deliver the first
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found so that's spotify itunes stitch or
public radio i already do catch box all
the places so every you listen to
podcast find us morning chose to leave a
five star review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are hope you guys
have an incredible day we will see you
tomorrow back in studio with jackie o a
claude and jax a jackson claude original
recipe we'll see you then goodbye
[Music]